this is Garfield we're doing this cuz
it's still fresh on my mind this fucking
movie god damned if when we were little
kids didn't we always talk about like a
Garfield movie and what it would be like
it won't be in it every one thing it
would have been animated yeah who says
this wasn't um but the whole thing would
have been animate you've already sorted
even if they did it all CG odd there's a
lot of a few times where it's a few made
it all CG I would have been okay that
would have been fine uh you know instead
you have to get these human actors that
act like not interesting animated
characters they anti characters from a
crib the end of the Christmas tree and I
don't know I it's one of those things
where it's like cuz we both really like
Garfield growing up I even said yeah
even the stuff that we knew wasn't good
like hey here's a Garfield picture book
of just him going to school Garfield
goes to school or something like that
but was still Garfield he'll still this
cynic you would still roll his eyes and
he was lazy and everything else
yes it's formulaic but I still find it
funny yeah mmm a TV show it's fine even
even there's not like a big bunch of I
like the TV show Garfield friends like
that was watching it again years later
it's so cheap I mean the animation and
the music and everything is Sookie how
they ins your budget but it was
confusing
yeah it was actually really good uh and
so much of it just centered around him
and what a likeable character he was in
it was it wasn't bound by any real sense
of reality it was like yeah okay it's a
cat in suburbia but he can walk on two
legs he cuz people kind of hear his
thoughts I was always the part that
confused prizes me how you have I mean
Jim Davis has been doing this for
decades
he's got the formula down to a science I
mean let's let's not be on and I mean
let's be honest here like Garfield is
formulaic it's you know a series of
similar jokes but they're all well put
together and they're funny um at least I
think they're funny probably have people
commute caffeine sacks but so I don't
get how when you have somebody who has
gotten this down to a science and done
this for decades
you can't just literally shit out a
movie that's prefabricated
at least serviceable hmm like this isn't
even a serviceable movie this is just
rock bottom and what's so fascinating
about is that they try to have it in
reality it's like you can't Odie's a
real dog and the mice are real might so
some even really reality but our field
is it with Scissorhands cartoonish
reality known open us I think it's it's
really for the most part just like
suburban homes and whatever and then
pets our pets and everything but like
Garfield looks like a fucking Martian he
looks so gross and Odie looks even
though he's a real dog almost looks
worse I mean it's just this ugly dog
well it's nothing like the original the
normals a joke and like none of my
characters are like wonderful didn't
blew my mind I'm just like when he
finally should feel when he said when he
said it ain't normal I was like where
I'm like what the fuck are you talking
about way not that cat what the Siamese
get what I'm like what like no Oh find a
great cat I think like the girl ki
always forget our name but like the girl
cat it was great it's not even the breed
of cat it's just the voice hmm like the
voice the personality normal normal
normal is supposed to be the cutest
wittle kitty cat on the planet and I'm
like and that's why
well how funny would that have been with
all the cat videos out there and all the
obsession we can to have normal in the
world
I mean that'd be hilarious and
interesting just in a UN age and the
movie seems strangely dog obsessed with
that damn dog yeah um then I'm like
really like we couldn't have made it
about like there's your better plot like
have have it be a competition between
Garfield and nermal for cuteness mmm
bring the Internet into it if you're
gonna go that stupid reality route like
I did when I was realizing the scene
where Odie goes in the middle of the
show it starts jumping eyes legs and
what go like that I really know one guy
I always tried to cut to whenever it's a
giant Petco sign that the game oh yeah
the camera always seems to have that
Petco sign somehow friend Wendy's and
penisy at Ace Hardware it's like ah but
um okay so they
uh that idea of OD going in just jumping
as legs and everyone standing applying I
could actually see that in a Garfield
special in that world complete Garfield
would be like doing something like he'd
be like a samurai you're doing flips and
kicks and something like that and then
Derek it's not sure yeah and creams with
her penny waters on the peyote will go
up and go like gavagai ha ha that would
be the joke and that would be funny but
there was no payoff and they didn't have
the reality that Garfield had you know
this really flexible funny reality is
like no it's pretty much just supposed
to be the real world except there's a
talking cat who you can't hear and such
a I'm hard-pressed to think of a movie
this I didn't see Terminator Genisys I'm
told that one's pretty miscast but this
shockingly like ridiculously
pathetically miscast wa take such a Bill
Murray with the exception of Hill Murray
every single person is absolutely wrong
including the dog yeah um including the
cat that plays nermal um that I didn't
mind that he was Siamese so much but I
don't I don't get it like how hard is it
to find somebody to play a goofy Jon
Arbuckle yeah I or be a geeky looking
Liz this was probably the probably the
closest but even she looks way too good
when she was way too nice I mean there
was some house to be geeky people and I
don't know I just yeah I mean it's it's
one of the things where it's like we
enjoy Garfield Garfield is not funny for
the jokes I mean whether you like the
jokes are not that is not the reason
Garfield's my Garfield's funny for the
people and for the personality isn't for
the characters these are cynicism yeah
these are such great characters and I
think that's why people relate to
Garfield so well is because I mean at
the time and even still kind now he
really does kind of represent this part
of America that wants to enjoy the
laziness and enjoy like yeah lazy and
death who cares and I'm cynical and I'll
make fun of stuff who cares
I'm me and there was kind of this player
it's like you know cool he's kind of
comfortable within it but he's also kind
of likable he's never quite goes too far
uh and even when he does he sort of back
tracks real
she's going too far uh and I guess they
were kind of getting that I mean
Garfield himself like once in a while
it's like okay that kind of seems right
or it seems like something he would do
and like I said Bill Murray's four-way
voice is very good for it but yeah it
just seems like we're just doing jokes
you know we will have this thing with
Odie which is kind of a constant story
arc that comes back with them but uh
aside from that it's just jokes who
would want that kind of exposure
I need a cat scan a cat scan oh and
we're going to Chuck E Cheese the jokes
aren't funny
yeah like a Garfield strip will make me
laugh not all the time but I still get
some laughs at I can't think of a single
joke that I laughed at in this film not
a one but that's the thing I can read a
Garfield strip and not laugh but still
feel good it's like oh that that's what
Garfield's up to like that's how good a
character it is uh yeah there was no
character in this movie yeah no and and
even even with like cuz that that is
true that like John and Liz I guess are
now dating uh I found this out during
research I haven't read in a while but
just like really okay a par Veet your
Cerwyn good for them good for them you
know I can finally I guess what they
moved on and we'll finally settles yeah
and all those things are ours just our
like you know what almost makes you want
to go in reading something bad
personality and Garfield knew how to
appeal to kids I liked the little
specials they did the Christmas special
is legitimately touching I love the what
was it babes and bullets yeah like they
don't adults are saying no how to grab
kids in and be good like the The
Specials knew how to be goofing grab
kids in I I I'm trying to think of films
I enjoyed as a kid I would've loved this
no I would have got more I would have
bored off my ass and thank God we didn't
have cell phones back then like we do
that we had cell phones like we do now
in the 80s yeah the whole movie I agree
sucks yeah I just would have been
sitting here playing games and I would
have looked up occasionally yep still
sucks and back to Angry Birds or
whatever but it just failed it feels
like a game on every level
we can't talking about I don't know this
came out the same time as Thomas the
Tank Engine but we are kind of talking
about how there was just this idea of
like you know
just do it throw whatever you want I
mean but make sure it stands to this
very make sure Garfield dancing to
black-eyed peas make that's what I
wanted to see yeah that that's oh you
know all the jazz and all the nice music
has been and all the specials and stuff
like then we get this you know let the
black-eyed be black eye peas are like
Cuban pop or something like that but how
the fuck is that Garfield like at all
you know it's not hey who's willing to
whore themselves out right now throw
that song in there yeah that's what
feels like it feels like just another
corporate sellout and we can do it for a
kid's film because movie was good oh
they'll see it with yell out the fact
that some people were just like ooh you
bring a band obscure but this is that I
I'm sorry this moon like somebody were
trying to argue this movie isn't a
corporate sellout because oh well God
there are products in real life and
therefore it's okay if they say oh yeah
there's a difference between oh a
product in the background and must show
the beginning of a Wendy's commercial
here just for a good devil show you will
see you shall full 10 seconds of a
Wendy's commercial then the know what
killed me was they there's Wendy's and
Petco ads everywhere and then on this
fucking model railroad he's a true
billboards oh yeah and it's Pepsi and
Wendy's I'm like oh what a coincidence
the only two things giant exist in this
world yeah like I'm like this is so
desperate so desperate it's just sad and
if somebody if people can't see them
they're like one of the goods are
corporate like get new glasses look at
contacts something like what what movie
were you watching you did I mean you did
notice it in Man of Steel alright I mean
a man some people are upset that you
just say the words Man of Steel Samantha
some people just take it down from you -
oh well some of you some people were
trying to say well you should have gone
with something like a crazy night sir I
I thought that was different because
honestly I thought the mall make more
sense within the context is erm like
well least she's having this flashback
or dreams or whatever in a mall when a
crazy night I went to Man of Steel so
it's like I'm just gonna do
yeah oh but I'm like this is this is so
blatant and the way the camera just like
I love the whole crowd setup at the
giant Petco sign in the background and
then Mikey he trips over the Petco food
and I'm like I have a sudden urge to buy
only Petco products here's the thing you
know it's it's an interesting
combination because a product placement
it's everywhere in movies and it's how
well can you disguise it or how well can
you even be blatant but funny with it I
mean you know use it to your exam is
funny it was no it wasn't funny and
there are times where it's like if it's
really all over a movie it's fine just
make it work for the movie and that's
why I think masks feel really pops out
to me because like that was like the one
really cool scene that action sequence
but they also put all those product
placement along where that's the funny
thing is in retrospect most of what I
remember from that is like oh yeah they
crashed into an IHOP like I odd no I'm
at IHOP Sears yeah the gas station every
if that's what you end up remembering
your stupid product placement is
distracting and Man of Steel got a lot
of shit not just from us from the
internet in general so in the few
defenders who want to defend the product
with the lizard you like Man of Steel is
a movie that's fine I don't care
that's you cannot even people I love it
or like know that profit point yeah but
even people that love them so if you are
going to the point we're gonna defend
the product place a Man of Steel your
arguments getting pretty rockbot just
defended as a movie me like I think it's
a good way that's fine but the product
placement then movie sucks well let's
keep this the car filled dance the
product placement in Garfield sucks
um it's just and we you know what blows
my mind to at least I can I can I can
think you know thinking like advertising
executives and and people who run these
corporations I'm like Man of Steel I'm
like okay if I'm gonna do a product
place in a movie I'd be like well there
was a big summer hit it's like who wants
to be associated with the Garfield movie
it was a hit it was a hit if they made a
sequel um I'll tell you I'll tell you
this and the opposite effect on me
because I never want to go into a
Wendy's or a Petco again so long as I
live I never did before anyway so I
don't you unless those notches that I'm
just like no no you can keep your square
hamburger size and I'm out
um but yeah I think when I saw the trail
for this movie I mean the first trailer
I'm like okay this is this is gonna be
like Smurfs or Alvin the chipmunk or
whatever like it's not gonna be the
product they're promising us and I feel
bad that they got though more if I could
just see it I'm like no this isn't gonna
wear John's way too good-looking od
doesn't look like Odie Garfield's
hideous oh they're dancing okay this is
for two-year-olds I'm not gonna like
this so when I'm finally forced to see
it because I know it'd probably be a
funny review and it's worth talking
about what a good character Garfield is
in my opinion cuz there was a time where
Garfield just ruled the world um where
you couldn't drive your car around
without seeing a Garfield such a yeah as
all over the kids too Bryant we had all
the merchandise and everything Oh
Garfield mugs sitting in the kitchen yet
you know what it is we have to his name
on it I'm gonna go get it you talked
about the movie I'm gonna go get it
I okay I guess he's gonna go get the mug
so um yeah this movie really blows I
don't know what the hell else to say
will you get back here yeah he's stuck
oh my god he's getting it out of the
dishwasher
this is desperate this is desperate this
is more desperate than the pod product
placement in the movies yeah
no no here we go yeah you want product
placement want product placement watch
traditional Garfield that's how much I
love Garfield I was a kid I still have
this mug oh well is it I love how it's
SMD a PI no that's not sure uh on the
reverse you got that late 80s I love
arisen mid 80s no late eighties yeah I
love home numbers though through the
viewfinder it says good good
cool odd it's it's God spelled backwards
what's missing you join my wrestling
when you were talking about the trailer
if I were an advertising executive and I
saw the trailer but like can I get my
product placement pulled Zach can you
see GI my product out of this and I
don't care of it it was a hit
nobody's sitting here saying this
movie's good hmm so I I just who would
want to be associated with Garfield the
movie not the Carroll and all the actors
that were in it kind of make fun of it
too there I feel like Mike J holding uh
but all the actors are a Bill Murray
obviously makes fun of it
Breckin Meyer Zach says Nia uh-oh is
normally hilarious very funny completely
miss can yeah
mushy much better movie him and then
watch rat race rat race watch a robot
jig well yeah robot shit I was trying to
find a robot chicken is when at some
point he plays himself in the show like
the stop-motion version and like it's a
behind the scenes thing and he's just
throwing a temper tantrum Nate this I
was a Garfield
like I mean they know what a movie so
universally hated even the stars are
making fun of it ya know Bill Murray in
Zombieland any regrets
Garfield maybe yeah I mean it's uh look
it up I mean that is all true they
thought it was one that going it's one
it's one Garfield just started dancing
to the black-eyed peas I'm like okay
this this is when I tried this is
trailer father this is desperation this
is something you cough up only when
somebody's put a gun to your head or
your cat and says give me something in
two seconds Garfield answer my
black-eyed peas dokyeom well yeah I mean
it's just so sad and desperate and a
little look at this this is just a mug
with a little Garfield I has the Navy
its corporate it's a set up of like that
that's Garfield that's each spreadsheet
II would have he's just painting is just
like hey I'm Garfield I don't care it's
just that that's who he is
and that's the power of the character I
mean he's so likable and it's just I
really didn't think you could so
misrepresent the feeling and the mood
and the likability of such a likable
character until I saw this movie oh and
you were right by about the special
effects by the way when we watch it the
first time I didn't notice the special
effects that much I was just like I
should see something with CG am I just
too yo nononono once you I have seen
once you mentioned it I think part of it
was I was so disinterested in the movie
I wasn't watching star video the cat as
a character I was just staring off in
the distance at other things a movie
once I watched the review and I was
looking at the scenes in particular
where like hold that err I'm like oh my
god yeah this is really fake no even
like I mean it's one of but it's like
why try we're gonna get kids to go see
it anyway we have our product plays
method why try you know
because it's Garfield and Garfield
awesome you know what kills me I would
have been happy if it was just an
animated cat that would have made this
much
fuck yeah I am drawn cat 2d animated and
you did it like Roger Rabbit what I made
is much sense and would have been
probably more entertaining and when that
make the world just a little bit more
surreal and you could get away with more
jokes that way and you could it could be
more like the world that Garfield
created where it is a very flexible
reality it can go to these extremes but
then it's like they still live in
suburbia but Doug you're thinking that's
the problem
yeah I um that's where I really want to
do is one cuz I love Garfield still get
the mug I got one grab another thing oh
my god this is like one of the first
things I bought like just as a decorator
wasn't like a poster or something like
that I remember I was 11 years old look
at that and I still have this thing
that's still how you look when you sit
in the lazy exactly good hmm I mean it
that that thought those those legs lady
reveals nothing's so that there you go I
mean that's this this is Garfield and
its corporate and it's trying to sell me
shit but I don't care because it's still
Garfield they got Garfield corporate
whores this weapon that this is more
Garfield in this these two inanimate
objects than in your entire movie and
it's just I think that's my feeling I
feel like I just watched you shrink into
a ten-year-old is this it oh yeah I
don't know I didn't realize how much I
actually really loved Garfield until I
saw how terrible it was done and how I
really just thought I could always love
this icon you know and then we see just
people don't really try and its
corporate but not not in a smart way not
in a way that's true to the character or
the world or the humor or the
environment um and yeah it's just it was
a bit of an eye-opener I guess um I
think again it isn't yours at that
that's the benefit of reviewing bamboo
because you really can see how not to do
certain things because this is still
corporate this is still merchandising
and selling out stuff but it's still the
character you got it this is who he is
he's never been the size of the sofa or
whatever but it's like you got it you
just sort of bites that flex
reality and this one there's too many
rules there's too much of the mice had
to be real mice but he has to be
computer-generated all the air pets have
to be real but they can talk and then
Odie can and then the people are real
people and it's just something where
it's like but it never goes full extreme
full cartoon full goofy and it just
plays it way too safe away to corporate
and not fun here's an idea Hollywood
give a shit really that's basically what
you need to do don't do a movie because
you're like oh well we can throw some
product placements in it or oh well it's
Garfield it sells itself
do it because you just want a good story
do a lego movie do it yeah does about
his obvious and advertisements you can
get him a movie was amazing it is the
fucking toy and the movies amazing
there's no way around that you can get
this is one big commercial but they put
their fucking everyone into it because
it seems like whoever was involved like
fucking Lego yeah and whoever was
involved with this didn't fucking like
Garfield or if they did they just said
and misguided and they want to help
himself but I don't know how so yeah so
um anger yeah loud voices again I will
say I don't know Garfield ever demand to
be a movie anyway to be honest I don't
know there is that ship sailed yeah it
went it's like this job and dumb
decisions movie came out it's just like
this is just sad yeah way way too late
like Garfield as a movie should have
come out early 90s yes well we're like
when the Phantom movie came out a family
opera is like no you waited way too long
yeah had to do this at the height
I'm afraid that's gonna happen with
wicked you know cuz it's like a wicked
movie would it really be fun but it's
like I think they're just waiting too
long now ants like it's gonna unless you
can really somehow revamp that ah we
offended now Garfield fans Simpsons fans
Broadway kid Phantom of the Opera
you know the fangirls are gonna rip you
apart for that one sisters how dare you
I love Gerard Butler - art pop art
dogged alright ha who's gonna do this uh
band up listen to him listen uh but to
send all your email to stop asking me
why he doesn't like it
no no if you like you're our Butler as a
singer uh contact your local psychic
no that is about you as I said ask him
he said it stop asking me on my public
Facebook well I mean you see of you know
all the singing roles he got after that
I mean people were just like please more
MORE Gerard Butler motors more singing
hey I'd rather we have Russell Crowe
okay again just another we've just said
more more Russell Crowe more singing
um but yeah uh like I said it was even
though I really had no desire to see it
it really did open my eyes about like
the right way but still a corporate way
clearly to do a character and represent
a character and this movie just did not
get it it just got way too corporate it
and not caring and it was during the
time when they just didn't care Isis is
around Alvin and the Chipmunks and I
think Smurfs and stuff what each other
but they're still crapping out those
moon no no but not like but this is back
when you know nobody could foresee
something like the lego movie or
something like that actually being good
and it to a point where we're mad it did
not get nominated for an Oscar that is
you know I mean nobody think the only
time we'd be mad is if Garfield and get
nominated for a Razzie yeah so yeah it's
a I guess in some respects it shows how
far we've come and just the more
seriously we're treating like family
entertainment which I say thank God you
know I gave you watching editorial on
that I talked all about it dog
Garfield's only there to advertise
Wendy's what else is there clearly
that's what the movie thought at Pepsi
and Petco and yeah fuck I love you
Garfield I love you I don't love the
movie I'm not calling it your mu because
you weren't in it but I do not love the
movie and I love you you're awesome
um Garfield
go read them go support him the real
Garfield suck the Real Ghostbusters yes
they have a rental music hey yeah go